Look closely--both axis are logarithmic and you can see as the step size increases by a factor of 10,
the error increases by a factor of 10⁵.
Remember, forward Euler was of order 1, Heun was of order 2. This is the solver of order 5.
Read this the other way around as you shrink the step size by a factor of 10,
the error decreases by a factor of 10⁵--that's a huge gain and you can see that this solver,
when it takes steps of 3 minutes around earth gets back to where it started within just millimeters.
This is quite an efficient method. It's called the Runge-Kotta feedback method.
Now assume that with all these strange numbers we mistyped one--
mainly we didn't enter 56,430 but we entered 56,431.
Let's look at the result. This doesn't look that great anymore.
We've got an error that's well above 1 km, so getting these numbers right,
which among other things belong to verification.